in south korea environmentalists have
taken an innovative approach to try to
reduce emissions
they filed a lawsuit on behalf of their
children parents are suing the
government saying the country needs to
reduce pollution for the well-being of
the next generation
even the yet to be born are represented
in this legal battle as dw reports
ee dong hyun is pregnant and worried
worried the planet will be too hot and
her unborn child won't have clean air to
breathe
she's so concerned she joined her fetus
to a lawsuit demanding the south korean
government do more to protect the
environment
my baby hasn't even been born yet and
hasn't emitted a single gram of carbon
dioxide into the world
i'm so concerned about the world that my
baby will face with so many disasters
that i joined this lawsuit
is one of about 60 co-plaintiffs under
11 years old who are mounting a
collective legal campaign lawyers say
may take years e says her unborn baby
offers a strong symbol
i believe not only the perspective of
the older generation but also future
generations should be fully considered
on issues surrounding the climate crisis
and there should be an open platform
where they can participate in this
discussion
south korean environmentalists are also
pushing for a shift in behavior across
from new president yun sukyo's office
greenpeace recently demanded he honor
his campaign pledge to ban internal
combustion cars by 2035.
we need effective leadership from the
president to tackle climate change and
to transition the domestic car industry
into eco-friendly cars changing our cars
is the most significant way to cut down
on greenhouse gas emissions
pollution affects more than just warming
the planet the issue of air quality had
become a regular concern with bad air
days prompting the government to warn
people to try to stay indoors as covet
19 declines and factories ramp up
production with more traffic it's
expected people will see more red on
their air quality apps
young people have mixed feelings about
the lawsuit they also recognize that
everyone needs to do more
a lawsuit might be a strong measure to
deal with this issue
but it seems better to have more
campaigns to change behaviors
they should take legal action only as a
last resort
expectant mother ee dong hyun admits her
fetus is a bit of an unusual claimant
on the day i first heard my baby's
heartbeat i went to the forest and saw a
woodpecker and i named my baby
woodpecker in korean and just like
woodpeckers want to live safely in the
forest i want the world and the
environment to be safe where our babies
will be born
for e and her baby more than the clock
is ticking
you